[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Peter Billingsley actor filmmaker
producer
you can bail if you want to Peter but uh
it's great to have you back A Christmas
Story Christmas currently streaming on
HBO Max and uh Peter is a producer
co-writer actor in the movie and uh the
top movie on the platform since
premiering on November 17th you're so
you're in two of the biggest Christmas
movies of all time two of the most
famous ones Christmas story and then elf
yeah
what questions do you get asked more
about Christmas story or elf
uh definitely Christmas Story the
interesting thing on elf um Favreau
asked me to come in and do a little part
in it and I didn't take credit
um I just said let me not take credit in
the role and so it's been fun to see
people realize and I'm gonna help and
they make this connection
um and then they're like well why didn't
you take credit and I said well it's
kind of more fun to see your face like
this now when you realize it
what question do you get about Christmas
Story
well I'll uh I'll tell you for me Dan
it's nice to be back with you because it
actually I think it's our third time it
doesn't really feel like the Christmas
season for me personally until I get a
chance to talk to you like the Christmas
story Whisperer for me thank you you've
pulled out a lot of a lot of good
stories
um I think probably most is it's more a
statement which is like people wanting
me to understand how much the Parker
family means to them and is their family
it's just like you don't understand
that's my dad that's my brother that's
my family that's my life and this film
is touched on such a deeply personal
connection
it's been 39 years Dan since we made the
movie
but why do certain movies take on a life
of their own long after like a slow burn
Shawshank Redemption I mean yeah for
sure I mean did okay I think was Oscar
Contender but then it's just one of
those movies when you turn it on
Shawshank I have the same reaction if
it's late at night and I turn on I'm
like ah damn now I have to finish it's
like you can't turn it off but you're
not in Shawshank just to let everything
[Laughter]
Ralphie's in Shawshank exactly but when
you go back and and take us back to when
you first auditioned for Ralphie
so I'll tell you a funny story about
that
um which Bob Clark the director told me
about so as a kid at the time I was I
think it was around 11 years old you get
all these auditions and it's kind of a
circuit you have many of them a week you
go and you read
and then maybe you get a call back so I
went to read for Bob Clark you read your
scenes and I heard nothing
um about three months later I went up to
do a screen test in Canada
um where they do all this mixing and
matching and so we had to read for I had
to read for flick and Schwartz and
everybody else and they do these
chemistry reads
um and so all the kids learn their lines
and it's funny because they always say
to you now don't worry if we tell you to
leave early it's not a bad thing but we
know that's not what you want you want
to survive to the end
and I got through the end got the part
bob later told me I was and it's just
how the schedule fell I was the first
kid he ever read
and he thought in that moment oh my gosh
this is Ralphie this is my guy but I
can't obviously hire the first guy that
I read so he went on a three-month
journey of reading and seeing kids and
it kind of LED back to me you have to
wait three months to find out that you
were the right person sometimes yeah
it's just sort of the way it falls and a
lot of those auditions you do and then
you figure all right well that's gone
you know
um you just sort of you just sort of
move on but nobody knew Dan at that time
I mean about how these things take a
life this movie you know it took 12
years to get made Bob Clark the director
had to throw his salary in to get it
done nobody wanted to do this movie full
of voice over set in 1940 you know it
was not a sexy leap off the page script
how do you act with your eyes
as Ralphie because your eyes are so
important in telling the story where you
don't have to say anything as much as it
felt like
you were telling a story without saying
anything
a lot of people have asked if you know
or even said all those glasses what a
great idea what a great prop look I
cannot I cannot see you now I was born
with a horrible vision
I was a I was diagnosed because I was a
front row student without the front row
student brain the teacher said I don't
think he could see because you still
have the glasses from A Christmas Story
I do I have some of those yeah and I
mean these are even similar so
but I think one of the things I love
about
Ralphie is a character and one thing
that we really pulled forward to the
sequel was that he's a dreamer you know
and he lives in his head in so much of
and I think that's relatable we all are
we whether we admit it or not we
fantasize about where our life could be
where we might want it and by the same
token he's kind of a nightmare in the
sense that he envisions things going
horribly wrong so he kind of lives in
his head so I think the expressiveness
of the eyes comes out of the fact that
he's in there in all that voice over
he's just constantly thinking
how long you've been sitting on trying
to make a sequel
I've thought about it for a while for
sure
um but it's been about four years that
we've actively been developing it and
the kind of impetus was I listen it's as
I said 39 is a little now or never I
think we're not getting any younger so
to get the band back together we had to
kind of do it now and it started with
Nick shank who's written a lot of movies
for Clint Eastwood is a friend and we
started kind of breaking the story and
and Nick has such a great tone and we
wanted to start with that grittiness of
the world and the tone but you're
reconnecting with your childhood friends
a hundred percent yeah Ralphie's a
father now he's sort of an unsuccessful
writer so he's in a place where he's not
really where he wants to be and it kind
of starts with the passing of the old
man and he's forced to go back home and
try to put on a Christmas like he had
growing up in the face of all that so he
reconnects he moves through town it
takes place in 1973 so we had to grow
sideburns which was nice and I'll tell
you
flick played by Scotch warts won that
contest he's got some real solid muttons
but you know you try to do that and I
don't know if you try to distance
yourself from Ralphie as you were
growing up
not really I mean I've Had The Good
Fortune of being able to do a lot of
other things and kind of have a another
career behind the scenes a lot of people
run from that I think you and I have
talked about this you'll have kind of
somebody that has a wildly iconic role
and they'll just say oh I don't ever
talk about that you know we can talk
about anything else but not that it's
like well we kind of want to talk about
that just for a moment at least but I
didn't have that plus as I said all the
approach of fans to me with this movie
it's pure joy Dan I mean people like if
if you don't like receiving that you're
in the wrong business
the the original you're in Indiana but
you shoot it in Ohio that's right yes we
shot in Cleveland and Canada both we
shot the exterior in Cleveland and then
the Interiors were in the studio in
Canada this one we shot in Bulgaria
which I know like why well to the
economy yeah I mean where else would I
mean Christmas in Bulgaria
like Bulgaria
um but actually interestingly looked
like it when you when it is sort of the
leaves are off the trees and the snow's
on the ground but it it actually allowed
us we built 11 houses so we built the
Parker House to Bumpus house next door
and then 11 houses on what's the old
Cleveland Street in the movie so it
really feels like you're transformed
back into the world and that was sort of
another reason of why I do this movie we
had to have the resources to be able to
do it right I describe it as we had to
play offense we wanted it to be great
but you got to play defense you got to
protect obviously against something
that's become borderline sacred now in
the first movie and so we had the right
resources also got to produce with Vince
Vaughn my good buddy which was great and
we had just really a great team
um and so the weight was worth it and
we're really really happy with how the
movie turned out he's Peter Billingsley
actor filmmaker producer A Christmas
Story Christmas currently streaming on
HBO Max when did that lamp become in
Vogue that people had to have that were
you involved at all with that no that
was that was sort of Gene Shepherd who
wrote all this Source material and was
radio host
um for wors where he started and did the
narration in the movie it was his
brainchild I mean what a wildly creative
concept
um and what I love about it is it's like
the old band doesn't care what it is he
just wants something he's he's gonna
make it a win it didn't matter what was
in there so at first he goes it's a
statue he could care less
and then it's like oh no it's a layup
even better and that thing people
started replicating them and you know
now they're everywhere I see them you
drive around you see them in people's
front room window even fragile I mean he
was my favorite line in the movie he was
such a brilliant comedian playing the
straight role but he Darren was so funny
so funny but also so dramatic so intense
I mean you look at that dad right that
feels like a dad he feels like he's an
inch away from just snapping or breaking
into my lips you know it's cold you can
tell his work sucks whatever he does
he's filling up antifreeze changing bald
tires I mean but
with all that you also never doubt the
love in the home you know what I mean
like it's it's just there that kind of
loyalty and love
um and so that's what I think makes it
feel very real I just um
I'm starting a podcast and so I um and
I'm breaking down Christmas movies
you've inspired me Dan I think all of
our Christmas Story conversations have
give me the confidence to make the leap
and we were breaking down Christmas
story is actually one of the movies
how much ad-libbing took place in the
original
very very little I so little in fact
that even the swearing that I did when
I'm beating up Scott Farkas was
scripted on note cards by Jean Shepard
what do you mean note cards
like little note cards like this so he
long hand wrote
um on the front and back and I think it
was three note cards and I was giving
them
a couple weeks before and said commit
these to memory okay um and I had to
memorize them
um and it was gibberish but you know
when you're filming you have multiple
angles so they wanted it to be
consistent when we covered it so I mean
even it wasn't just like yeah it just
kind of mumbles something and be angry
and start screaming uh it was no you
need to say this it was like a very
precise script they've been working on
it for 12 years so by the time we went
the level of preparation was unlike
anything I had ever seen
I know at that time so you're 11 or 12
and and you're getting into dangerous
territory of now kids can make fun of
you or you're not at an awkward time I
didn't know if if school was tough
you're wearing the bunny outfit and you
know there's there's a lot of things
that they either embrace you because
you're a star or they make fun of you
what was school like for you
um it's yeah some people embrace you a
lot of them
make fun of you but I I was a homeschool
kid because you're traveling so much
okay so I tried to I mean I I
unceremoniously got left back in the
eighth grade
um partly because of my grades but
mostly because I just wasn't there so I
took my GED when I was I think 15 and
then was the high school graduate at
that point
um so it was really a sort of sort of a
life of tutors
um and classroom and you know on set
School teachers and then was doing
homeschooling at home I was traveling at
times oh so that that probably helped
cushion a little bit you you still have
the BB gun I do Bob Clark the director
gave me
I don't know I I might be the only
original one that has a nice plaque on
it and the other prized possession is
and this is the only one that was ever
made as the original bunny suit and
those are in a climate controlled Vault
that I keep they're actually valuable
now nobody yes we just you always take a
little something you know when they're
rapping out in the costume departments
and disarray you're like oh can I have
this sure
you hung out with Vince Vaughn in the uh
the swingers era didn't you mm-hmm yeah
I yeah I'm at Vincent 80 1989. that
feels like that's that's the real Vince
Vaughn is who we see in swingers so many
great sites to Vince but for sure just
that Charming funny great loyal friend
who loves to go out and have a great
night
um and there's also no one better to get
you out of a funk if you're in one you
know he's just got a contagious energy
um it's fun and and is was is and was
great at not taking no for an answer
uh you didn't take no for an answer
because you uh you got the sequel made
and uh it's great to talk to you again
always great to reminisce there and uh
thanks for joining us yeah thanks Dan
always always good to see you Mary
Christmas to you yep you too Pete that's
uh Peter Billingsley thanks pal actor
filmmaker producer A Christmas Story
Christmas and uh also it's a podcast
cinematic Journey on Spotify which
focuses on holiday films